lisa kriegt sogar nice wenn es etwas
gibt das ich über alles liebe dann ist
das pizza und mein bett beides davon hat
nichts mit dem heutigen video zu tun
meine damen und herren denn viele leute
haben mir einfach zugesendet hey kannst
du mal auf long island reagieren erst
mal um die frage zu beantworten was live
island überhaupt ist jeder solle [ __ ]
wäre auf rtl 2 1 auf island lebt eine
gruppe von kandidaten die islander
genannt werden isoliert von der
außenwelt in einer villa auf mallorca
unter ständiger beobachtung von
videokameras also quasi wie big brother
nur auf malle um in der villa bleiben zu
können muss man mit einem anderen
islander verbandelt sein ob es nun aus
liebe ist eine freundschaft die
grundlage bildet oder aus berechnung
man bleibt drin wenn man sich am ersten
tag verkuppeln sich die highlander zum
ersten mal basierend auf dem ersten
eindruck es hört sich an wie so
genmanipulierte tiere wurden gesagt mit
her am ersten tag vermehrt ihr euch dann
am zweiten tag nochmal im laufe der
staffel sind die teilnehmer allerdings
gezwungen sich immer wieder neu zu
verkuppeln
sie werden gezwungen sich dann eine
andere person zu suchen
die pärchen müssen dann die zeit
gemeinsam verbringen auch gemeinsam in
einem bett schlafen die müssen
stellt euch mal vor da kommt der ingo an
und denkt sich hey ich geh mal auf
island ich werde bestimmt den finden
findet aber keine personen anziehend
muss aber um in der show zu bleibt mit
wem anderes schlafen das ist dass beide
kranke scheiße ja und auf eine folge
dieser serie reagieren wir heute macht
euch richtig schick erster eindruck das
sorry das war so dumm pause steht aber
dass rtl2 keine ahnung warum nicht
einfach das bild zeigen wo man pausiert
hat die sehen alle aus wie die größten
vollidioten
sorry aber der oder die oder der wir
sehen halt wirklich aus als würden sie
von 24 stunden am tag tatsächlich 24
stunden im fitnessstudio verbringen
und anstatt bücher zu lesen lesen sie
die packungsbeilage von eiweiß macht
euch richtig sie hält an
[Musik]
was ich wissen was das war wir hören den
lockruf des balzenden menschen zu
das ist ja das ist ja echt einfach nur
ekelhaft paarungszeit
das ist doch alter die vögel dann vor
laufender kamera oder was wollt ihr mich
verarschen was macht ihr denn da
sichtschutz
seid ihr bescheuert seht ihr uns macht
sorry aber die sind doch alle dumm wie
brot wer ohne partner bleibt der fliegt
das ist das ist ja echt so ein
bescheuertes format mehr wer keinen
partner findet fliegt einfach raus was
rtl 2 da immer auf die beine stellen das
ist echt wahnsinn qualitäts werden
sicher viele street und wenn es am ende
wird alles gut
wenn es nämlich gut ist mein gott ich
weiß nicht wie der typ heißt aber hey du
bist nicht küsse er ist mit einer sex
show auf rtl 2 und sagt seinen kollegen
bruders treten wenn das am ende wird
alles gut ist noch nicht gut ist meine
fresse das ist ja der wahnsinn
das sieht ja ganz schön gemacht aus
nahrungs zeremonie wie harms zeremonie
muss sie alles riskiert sogar den auszug
aus der villa
dieses warten allein fast auf eine
scheiße ich weiß nicht ob das bisher
richtig rübergekommen sondern wir müssen
euch einfach mal vorstellen das ist eine
serie wo zehn oder zwanzig keine ahnung
wie viele leute auf einer insel sind in
einem haus und um in der nächsten folge
mit dabei zu sein müssen sie nicht wie
beispielsweise bei let's dance tanzen
können oder wie bei dsds oder was weiß
ich was gut singen können die müssen
sich einfach nur den anderen typen oder
eine andere frau suchen und buchen
also das ist wahnsinn so werden stars
gemacht nachricht die so schreibt man so
rum wenn wir eine nachricht kriegs oder
es hat als unding für alle
wahrscheinlich liebe hält endlich einzug
auf der insel und deswegen darf auch
heute ein paar die nacht in der privaten
oben mein gott ich bin gespannt wer es
sein wird hashtag velde magic happens ja
eh alles bereit oder yannick und lisa
meine damen und herren dürfen die
privates wie der kammer tasche
schreibt mir die kommentare hättet ihr
gerne yannick und lisa darin gesehen
oder doch stand alle und charline und
wir freuen uns sehr darüber dass man
auch mal abends oder nachts alleine
verbringen kann wenn du den abend oder
nachts alleine verbringen willst dann
fahr gefälligst hause wir haben
vorgesorgt wahlweise mit wickeln oder
mit erdbeergeschmack das ist ja wahnsinn
da steht einfach champagner erdbeeren
und gleitgel wow rtl2 also ihr
übertrumpft euch echt immer wieder ich
zeig dir erstmal die riesen street erst
mal zu machen von außen aber dann ist
trotzdem noch ein kamerateam drin in den
haag steht noch gleitgel alles so pinkl
das sieht einfach nur scheiße aus und
erst mal ein bus mit kanus seit ein paar
tagen lisa kriegt sogar nice krise krieg
sogar ein eis mensch lisa warten sind
also soll die nacht deines lebens tor
wollte erst mal sagen dass ich sehr froh
wenn wir zusammen sind während du für
mich eine wunderschöne frau bisher hat
hör auf mit der scheiße hast du tolle
ausstrahlung eine tolle ausstrahlung auf
gott nein wer du kennt sie seit ein paar
tagen bernd und wollte dich mit dieser
geste hier fragen ob die offiziell meine
freundin sein möchtest
oh mein gott ist das lächerlich
überrascht
wahnsinn erst mal der werbung habe ich
schon noch nie eine show ohne werbung
alle drei sekunden
auch ehrlich ich gar keine werbung ich
aber nutella bildungsprämie heftig geil
da kann ich dann endlich mal weiter geht
mittlerweile
jetzt gegen die zu zweit baden darin in
badehose zeigst du mir deine störche
künste ach du grüne neune das ist ja
schlimmer als vista was schwester video
[Musik]
was hat es gebracht das auch ist er
komplett dunkel jetzt da drin also ihr
seid ja echt fremdscham pur bis zum
flippig das ring im griff zudem gibt's
immer noch ergründen sorry aber diese
janine wie die da dieser zeit gelacht
hat und wie der tobias doktor love das
hat auch nachgeäfft hat menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend allein nur in
dieser folge habe ich nicht mal ein
viertel geschafft ich bin der raw datei
bei 45 minuten reaction type und ich
meine es gibt eine komplette staffel 1
mit 22 volk und es gibt eine komplette
staffel 2 mit 22 folgende und ich war
gerade glaube ich bei tage 17 hat sie
mich erwartet noch so 40 millionen
stunden voll mit gags die scheiße nicht
mit mir freunde habt ihr live angeschaut
schreibt für die kommentare
ich hoffe dich
[Musik]